this is a plume of white phosphorus
a banned chemical which burns human skin
azeri forces
alleged this was fired on a civilian
area by armenia
both countries accuse each other of
using the illegal munition
but deny using it themselves it's the
first time international media has been
allowed into territory retaken by azeri
forces
destroyed tanks and unexploded rockets
are everywhere
the gorgon village post was of strategic
importance with its bunkers and supply
routes
retreating armenian troops left these
shells and thousands of rounds
helmets boots sleeping bags and uniforms
littered the fields on the way to
fizzily
the town was captured by the armenian
military in 1993
and most of it is in ruins now among the
people taken to the town for a tour
arranged by the azeri government
were some homeowners from fizzily
the entrance to my house was from the
other side but now bushes and trees have
overtaken my three-bedroom house with a
kitchen and a big yard
i'm very sad what's the reason why did
they grab and destroy all these houses
waggy also lost his home and he says he
used to be the head of the theater
in fiscally 27 years ago in the business
the oldest building of foosoli was a
theater it was an architectural marvel
and a hundred years old it's not far
from here but now it's damaged beyond
recognition
where we stand now used to be a busy
street and a luxurious part of the city
now it's just hurtful and upsetting
despite yerevan's territorial claims
fizzily has largely remained a ghost
town
armenia captured it in 1993 but the
hundred thousand plus population in and
around fiscally was never replaced
it's not clear whether it was
systematically damaged or just neglected
for nearly three decades
the azeri president says shortly after
the deal that ended the conflict and
forced armenia to hand over territory to
azerbaijan
construction is set to begin on a 29
million dollar highway
that will link fizzly to the second
largest city of shusha in
nagorno-karabakh
and according to him the enemy will be
held to account
armenia as a state bears a
responsibility for
such an actions of the war crime crimes
against humanity including the
policy of vandalism and based on that uh
assessments of course we will continue
uh to
appeal international institutions
including the international
uh courts so that to sue armenia those
displays from fiscally say their mosques
have been destroyed and graves of their
ancestors are desecrated
they say what gives them strength is
knowing they're no longer displaced
and will be able to rebuild their homes
looking at the destruction it's hard to
imagine how this was
once a bustling city with tens of
thousands of people
people here say they're emotional when
they've come back and they're ready to
rebuild their lives
as soon as they get the go ahead osama
bin laden